as vaccination efforts continue across
our state many have expressed different
reactions to the vaccine
regardless of which brand or which dose
it's important to know that you're not
alone
christian joins us in studio with more
on the possible side effects you could
see from the vaccine
and it really is a case-by-case
situation it really is kirsten according
to the cdc the vaccine may have some
side effects regardless of the brand
that you get
but this is normal which means your body
is building protection and should fade
away
in a few days now first of all let's
talk about your arm and
when you get the shot now right here is
a list of some of the things that you
may be feeling
you may be feeling some pain some
swelling some chills and
fever now some can experience some or no
symptoms which also include a little bit
of fatigue
so you can basically just have a little
bit of fatigue headache muscle pain
chills
nauseous or fever now the cdc says there
are some things that you can do
to hopefully make you uh feel better
like obviously putting
apply a clean cool wet washcloth over
the area use or exercise your arm
maybe just move it around just a little
bit and obviously drink plenty of fluids
and dress slightly now if the pain
continues
for several days they do recommend you
please call your doctor now during
today's covet call
uh this with the state and the health
officials they said that there is
no date yet as to when nevada will reach
the 60
vaccination marker within the population
because they are still waiting on
more data from the cdc another concern
was tracking those individuals who
tested positive for covid after being
fully vaccinated
which is which officials say is
information that is being collected
on a regular basis as more restrictions
roll back
we asked about concerns for out-of-state
residents or even tourists
coming to southern nevada looking to get
vaccinated and this is what they told us
i think we have to be careful because we
might have individuals who just move
here
you know within within a short period of
time and don't have
their particular identification switched
over and things like that so we just
have to be careful that we're not
creating a barrier while also trying to
support vaccination in the state
well the topic of vaccinating inmates
was also brought up
this is the group that was moved up on
the state's priority list and according
to health officials
the elderly population has begun to get
vaccinated
and education of the vaccine to that
group is currently happening
to see how many doses are needed now
officials
also added that they are using reminders
like text messages to get people
to return for their second dose a simple
reminder to get
everyone protected and obviously keep
the community safe
christian gossip is 8 news now